we have a responsibility to act that's
what's happened in Libya over the course
of these last six weeks since at least
the collapse of the Soviet Union and the
end of the Cold War American foreign
policy has been drifting comprising a
series of ad hoc interventions absent a
national consensus about when to use
force and lacking an underlying set of
reliable core principles that drift
continues with President Obama's speech
about our war in Libya and includes the
simple fact that our commander-in-chief
couldn't even acknowledge that we're in
a war and that we've taken sides against
someone he calls a tyrant who murdered
opponents at home and abroad and
terrorized innocent people around the
world including Americans who were
killed by Libyan agents dropping bombs
shooting missiles deploying massive
amounts of personnel and power all of
these are generally understood as acts
of war but Obama can admit that were
waging war because then he would have to
acknowledge what his critics correctly
underscore constitutionally he doesn't
have a right to do this sort of thing
unilaterally when the country isn't
facing a clear and present danger we
know this because of Obama himself in
2007 while a senator and presidential
candidate he flatly told The Boston
Globe the President does not have the
power under the constitution to
unilaterally authorize a military attack
in a situation that does not involve
stopping an actual or imminent threat to
the nation no president was worse at
foreign policy than george w bush who
came to power amid promises of a humble
foreign policy and then mired us in two
intractable conflicts that even
supporters grant were poorly executed
under his command yet even Bush pushed
to get a fig leaf of authorization from
Congress before the shooting began
Obama's Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton instead brandish unanimity among
NATO leaders as proof we were doing the
right thing as if NATO a Cold War
Alliance conceived to protect the free
nations of Europe from a threat that
went missing 20 years ago is a
substitute for the American people and
their elected representatives
who knows how long we'll be in Libya
whether under us or NATO command it
might be a few months or it might be
many years but this much is certain our
actions there one have been authorized
by the American people and they provide
no guide to where we'll end up next for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie